how to relationship
from an expert I'm going to the bathroom
all right
I told you I don't commit to women who
take their phones into the bathroom
I just forgot this one time okay
okay
so are we good then
yep I called you an Uber
this is so petty call it what you want
but this is how I move and you've known
this from the start
ladies don't pretend you've never texted
an ex in the bathroom or swipe for
sausage on Tinder while in the shower or
God knows what else you don't want your
man to find out about
hey Kim wants to go to a concert tonight
cool can I go
what are you asking me for I'm not your
father
well you said you don't commit to women
who go to concerts
indeed I did
so what happens from here well you can
either choose to go to the concert or
stay in a relationship with me
all right
let's keep going
open the car door for the lady for the
date that's good oh ladies first for now
obviously once you get married tell that
[__] to open up all the doors for you
but at the beginning you do ladies first
reservation for Donovan Donovan Sharp
thank you
how do you pronounce your name by the
way
Dahlia yes that was flirting how do you
pronounce your name Adelia
that's hard I'm sorry I'm sorry I like
how he says convo slash light flirting
with the hostess in front of your
girlfriend
in caps in front you want to make sure
she sees you light flirt
he's better
I can't figure it out guys
make sure you walk in front of your
woman
do not let her walk in front of you
because the man comes first and is she
behind you because she could see if you
got cakes or not pups what you just said
made those things
I don't know yeah you don't yay sus
the only place I've been with my girl I
wore first is places I don't know
Fair like let's say I go we're not in
the country like I said we go to coupe
right you protect you're just protecting
it's just that yeah it's just old school
way of doing things yeah if a bullet
comes flying you dying that's just fine
yeah I mean somebody come with it with a
knife and I could do the whole thing
when I die in the arms you know yeah
like a real man stupid you know what
makes you die like a real man what if
you got a mustache
all you hairless [__] in your
late 20s can't grow a beard [__]
dweep I can't grow beer
you're not supposed to let them know
that I can't but you're supposed to say
this is a choice you Brave man you Brave
man
avant-garde okay yeah you got beard I
got Patches [__] there's some little
Asian kid who needs hair I'll send it to
them
send it to me
okay so she is going to do for uh
appetizer she's gonna go with a wood
grilled corn aged cheddar or spiced
bacon
uh for dinner she's going to go with the
field green salad
and the uh the wood grilled main lobster
tail
I am going to go with the lobster bisque
for uh appetizer and then I'm gonna go
with the uh the lamb loin it's going
across the lamb loin uh medium hashtag
well-trained woman that can still end up
cheating on you stop
and if I'm the waiter I'm like what's
wrong with this one her eyes glued to
the floor she held hostage so your girl
can't make contact with the waiter why
hold up why I just want to hear why oh
because it's disrespectful I'm the man
she should only be looking at me let me
ask you when your girl goes to work does
she look people in the eyes or does she
never make eye contact does she see a
male customer and then avert her gaze
what are we talking about
are guys so insecure now okay and I mean
you have to be deeply terrified of being
hurt by somebody to think that her
making eye contact with somebody at a
service job is an issue and you think
that's a sign well-trained dude I think
you just need some therapy I think you
need to do some healing because I've
seen some videos of past traumas you had
and it sounds like you still living with
them
yeah mm-hmm
yeah it's a fraud he's not even acting
like that with his girl I think I think
he doesn't he doesn't even act like that
they're they're setting up this [__] and
they're in it together and that's it he
said you know what that's how we're
gonna bamboozle a whole bunch of people
are you in or not you're gonna play a
role maybe that's the role-playing game
that they do like in the bedroom and
that extends to uh you know what let's
make some money with that and we're
gonna do that we're gonna play that um
that's kind of guy but I'm not but
that's a con that's a con that's not
real that's not how we really acts he's
not really like that with his girl and
it's just really just to get you guys
and I don't even know if it works or
whatever but no that's not it the acting
is so bad it's not real [__] it's not
real it's scripted is so bad it's so bad
if you really
that's entertaining but that's not it
that's not that's not what it is that's
not what it is if you think if you
really think that that's really how life
Works God damn my guy
well you're sad too and that's not how
life works that's not how any of this
works so now we're gonna hear an origin
story from
Donovan himself at 32.
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
guys the Reader's Digest version I
started paralegal school when I was 31
years old and there's this there's this
hot hot 19 year old in my class we took
a shine to each other immediately right
it was a great relationship we spent
every day together blah blah blah red
flag number one that I didn't even think
about one day I had a headache in class
she says what's wrong I said well I've
got a headache she's like all right
reaches into her purse and she gives me
this big white pill I'm like what is
that she says it's Vicodin what's a 19
year old doing with a bag full of
Vicodin right red flag number two she
had homemade tattoo on her wrist stay
with me red flag number three she had a
six-year-old
she was 19 years old who had a
six-year-old which means what class she
had her child at 13 which means she was
having at 12. it gets even better the
baby daddy
was in prison at the time we were dating
oh statutory statutory epar here's the
reason why they didn't throw the book at
him with Jessica's law is because she
testified to the jury that she seduced
him and the jury actually bought it
was first all the part all the parts the
whole thing you want these real skull
cap what caps it's all caps ass caps I
don't believe it's real
a jury's not gonna believe
no in America I've seen worse
she left her account open on my computer
on Facebook I scrolled through saw all
kinds of stuff drove to her place I said
I want you to be honest with me have you
cheated on me I wanted her to lie to me
and I I wanted her to lie to me so I
could just keep up the delusion she said
honestly yes that is the worst the worst
emotional pain I've ever felt in my life
to this day I never will dude I dude I
went to her bathroom I puked ripped off
the necklace she's blowing him she's
blowing me up at work all day long I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't pick
up the phone so finally I picked up the
phone she's like hey I'm sorry you know
I want to spend the rest of my life with
dude she's like look I want to come to
your place I have a birthday surprise
for you so she comes over she has like
this little cupcake and she bought me a
watch that she knew I was looking at
then she turns around and lifts up her
shirt there was my name tattooed on the
small of her back dude my hand to the
man so I was back in her I was back in
her clutches things went all it was all
downhill from there guys this story gets
so much worse how old were you I was 31
I was 31 years old yeah
hold up I believe this is real
at 31 years of age
you got played by a 19 year old
good Lord
this is really pathetic she continued
cheating on me right so I'm always
trying to catch her I lost my job I lost
the place that I was at I the car that I
had was paid for because I paid cash for
it broke down I didn't have a job so I
couldn't get it fixed I'm evicted I
ended up having to live with a couple of
her a couple of her drug addict friends
in a quasi crack house and I kept I kept
trying to get back with her September
16th baby daddy gets out of prison okay
baby daddy gets out of prison I called
her up on September 15th I said you know
what I can't do it I think you still I
think you still love Ben I can't do it
anymore dude she cried her eyes out hung
up the phone I stayed up all night long
I couldn't sleep so I called her up I
called her up the next day I was like
hey um you know meet me at this meet me
at this gas station
then I called up my brother and I
borrowed 800 he gave me 800 I went to
the jewelry store I bought her a ring
proposed to her I proposed listening
this guy was a cornball at 18 when he
frauded his father
he was a cornball at 31 as a career
Criminal Who was borrowing money from
his family to buy a ring for a crackhead
19 year old and he's a cornball in his
40s when he's lying about his girl being
a single mom even though he said he
would never date a girl like that
gotcha stays being a horned horn ball
now I don't like to judge people before
they pass but when your past looks like
you're present boo boo
I mean
rough
she's 19. it's not that special
she's an attract it's not that special
the only reason you think it is
because you're a loser
that's it and it's okay but when you get
on these platforms and trying to educate
men like you top dog
but then we just have to look at your
history and find out oh
you bottom [__]
listen it gets worse it gets worse I
swear to God people want listen people
wonder why I speak with such conviction
about these things dude
out of it it looks it gets worse it gets
worse so she says yes right so now you
know all of her friends are like oh
she's getting engaged well eventually
she started [__] the baby daddy
behind my back of course so we were in
this we were in this love triangle
anytime she was pissed off at me she'd
go and [__] him anytime she was pissed
off at him she would come and she would
come and meet me so finally on
Thanksgiving
um this girl calls me up and tells me
that she was now engaged to be married
to Ben right I'm crushed I'm heartbroken
I'm crossfallen during the summer during
the summer she lost an exorbitant and
she was already a small girl she lost an
exorbitant amount of weight I found out
that she was shooting heroin All Summer
Long
okay okay all right you win bro I can
see I can see you were right
let's keep listening to his money
against worse gone she got arrested for
possession the guy the people I was
staying with had called the cops and
ratted her out so now she's in jail
right and of course and of course I have
to save my fair Maiden I called up an
old roommate and borrowed 1350 to bail
her out she gets out I love you I love
you then goes right back to Ben this is
why people always wonder why I'm such a
I'm such a I'm so passionate and I'm so
sure I have seen the worst I've been in
the worst of the worst situations it is
the worst situation I have ever been in
cat
that's my version and that's it you hear
me this guy's a big fraud story and if
he's not frauding or he's not frauding
then he's a giant simp loser who
basically took money from everywhere
around him to finance I saw the worst of
the worst out with all your decisions
that's why you saw the worst of the
worst it was all you [__] you mean I
mean listen I've taken some big girls
I've shared the stories here but I was
1918 at 31 you were getting lost in the
sauce over 19 year olds
good Lord
well hey man listen I ain't got much
commentary for this one this guy's just
a big dweeb and every time I watch
videos I'm just like this is the person
you guys are taking the cues from this
is the kind of relationship y'all want
to emulate
okay you have to ask yourself if he's
one of the only or the few people
spreading the truth quote unquote why is
it that he can't apply any of that to
his life to lead something that seems
quite desirable
anything else you want to say oh
absolutely not all right let us know
what you guys think in the comments